des masques sur tous les visages la
règle est respectée dans cette classe de
troisième
les 600 élèves du collège jacques
cartier aïssou applique les gestes
barrière hormis trois élèves
donc la grande majorité avait bien
entendu leurs masques puisqu'il avait
été bien sûr prévenus en amont 160000
protection ont été distribués dans les
collèges publics et privés par le
département des yvelines
un investissement de 415 mille euros
c'est une première dotation
elle sera suivie d'autres si les
conditions sanitaires le nécessitait le
gouvernement a imposé le port du masque
pour des raisons sanitaires
on peut tout à fait comprendre sans
fournir ces masques aux collégiens le
département a la responsabilité des
collèges et nous avons choisi de fournir
deux masques par collégiens pour les
professeurs leur tour c'était déjà hier
à villepreux l'équipe du collège léon
blum a fait sa prérentrée sur deux jours
une période un peu spécial qui modifie
les façons d'enseigner ce qui me gêne
davantage c'est le port du masque qui
est un peu contraire
à notre pratique habituelle et qui
constitue presque une entrave en tout
cas à la transmission des apprentissages
sanitaire déjà ne serait-ce qu
identifier les élèves ça va être
compliqué pour les élèves de 6e ce qu'on
connaîtrait pas se rendre audible
essayer de repérer les émotions sur les
visages des élèves malgré le port du
masque obligatoire l'équipe du collège
se sent sereine
en juin il avait déjà accueilli 95% de
ses élèves
on a déjà profité de ce premier temps
pour préparer la rentrée de septembre ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
globalement je pense que les familles
les élèves sont en confiance au collège
léon blum et que nous nous sommes prêts
à les accueillir pour cette rentrée deux
défis protéger les élèves du virus et
rattraper le retard pédagogique c'est de
faire en sorte qu' on puisse évaluer le
niveau d de nos élèves ceux qui pendant
quelques semaines n'ont pas été au
collège où l'école ou au lycée cette
semaine plus de 310 mille élèves ont
fait leur retour sur des bancs des
collèges yvelinois